The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
Assessment for this class
was probably the hardest
thing for me, at least.
How to assign a fair
grade to students, because
at the end of the day,
they're a grade for this.
And it wasn't going to be
an A for effort type thing.
It was actually really
hard because anything
that requires creative effort--
I talked to you about this
for a long time-- you
don't want to crap
on people's creative efforts,
even if it's just not
very good.
CHRIS BOEBEL: It's very hard.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Jamie and
I talked a lot about this.
But initially, the rubric was
very plastic elements based.
Like, is this well lit,
can you hear the audio OK?
And we just kind of scrapped
that, and really went
with-- there were four sort
of principles to the class
that I talked about on the
first day, which was spark,
does it foster curiosity,
and that was like a big theme
that went through every
single assignment,
and how it manifested change
assignment to assignment.
You can see on the rubric.
Kill your darlings.
Like, is it concise enough.
There are a couple others.
So that's how we
approached grading.
And we assigned them
raw numerical scores,
and we didn't have like, an
A is 20, a B is 10, or 15.
It was in progress was from 0
to 5, and steps moving forward
was like five to 10, and then
mastery was like 10 to 15,
for instance.
So they would get
numerical grade feedback.
We gave a lot of weight
to their daily reflections
so that not everyone in the
class would end up with a C.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I
have a question.
Do you think grading should
have been A for effort?
Because in real life, and
I didn't tell this to you
when we were planning the
course, and I'm sorry.
But in real life, it
almost is A for effort.
If I show up to do voice over
and I'm late and I'm sloppy,
and I don't do a
very good job, I'm
not going to get hired again.
And part of that is my technical
ability to do voice over.
And part of it is showing
up 15 minutes early,
being professional,
all that sort
of stuff, which does kind
of seem like A for effort.
I don't know.
What do you think?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Well.
So I've had to think
about this a lot
for the course I teach at MIT.
And it's a huge,
huge issue because,
so who should get
the better grade?
The person who has a huge
amount of talent and experience
as a filmmaker and
video maker, sluffs it,
just like lays back
throughout the whole course,
but does a really
nice piece at the end.
Or the person who never
has done it before,
doesn't necessarily
have a whole lot
on the ball, when it
comes to media production,
but just works and works
and works and comes out
with something that's
kind of mediocre.
Just because by the nature of
it having never done it before.
That's really the issue.
When you're dealing
with non-professionals--
because I completely
agree with him,
it's the Woody
Allen thing right?
Like most of life is showing up.
And it's totally true.
But when you're dealing with
this huge, huge learning curve,
it becomes very, very tricky.
So what we do, we don't
do quite A for effort.
But we do kind of allow an out
if your final project, which
is a big part of your grade,
goes completely haywire
and just falls apart
on you, you can
write a fairly
substantial paper that
describes what your intents
were or what your thought
process was, what
went wrong, why
it went wrong, what you
would have done differently.
And so, essentially, you do have
a way supplementing or making
up for this innate
problem you had,
which was that you didn't know
what the hell you we're doing.
Which is a problem.
JOSHUA GUNN: It's
fairy innate for me.
ELIZABETH CHOE: For all of us.
Well, two of the course
values were challenge,
and a lot of that
manifested in the rubric
in the final project and
the graded assignments,
as is their improvement
from the previous iteration?
Is this person going outside
of their comfort zone?
And then thoughtfulness.
Can you tell that this
person has integrated
some of the things we talked
about in class, whether it's
through their blog posts,
or just like office hour
reflections, things like that.
So that was built
into the final grades,
but then I would also say that
the graded sort of quality
projects, and the
daily reflections
were weighted pretty
equally so that if you
had a student, which we
did, who had the skills,
but didn't do the daily
blogs, their grade would
suffer a little bit more.
Just as much as someone
who did the daily blogs,
and just could not
host for instance.
In the end it worked out
by doing it that way.
All the students who
I thought deserved
great grades, because I knew
they worked really hard,
got good grades.
And all the students who
were very technically skilled
still got decent
grades, but it wasn't
like they got 100 or anything.
It's always a tough
challenge, though.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: My
math teacher used
to say-- we'd be like, how are
you going to grade this test.
He'd be like, well I'm going to
blindfold myself, turn around
and throw darts behind my back.
And we were like, good.
That's good.
CHRIS BOEBEL: I
just which I could
have written a paper in
chemistry class in college
to make up for the--
GEORGE ZAIDAN: My
experiment went south.
And here's what happened.
ELIZABETH CHOE: It's hard
because MIT students,
they want to know what
do I need to do to--
CHRIS BOEBEL: Exactly.
People are very focused on
achievement and doing well.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
Which is why I was
very conscious of by creating as
specific of a rubric as I can.
JOSHUA GUNN: That
makes lot of sense,
especially as you said before,
because this is a form of art,
and there is no right or
wrong answer, so how do you--
ELIZABETH CHOE: But
you can tell someone,
look you didn't change
anything from your first draft.
So you're going to get docked
for points on challenge,
as the rubric says.
Or you straight up didn't
do a blog reflection
so you're getting a
zero on that section.
But at least I do
think that there
has to be something
tangible to go back
to that you can't just sort
of arbitrarily assign a grade.
I will say that, at
the end of the day,
an assessment, a
great assessment,
should be a reflection.
Or should be there to
help students improve.
And I do think that the value
in assessment and feedback
came from just sort of one
on one, when you all worked
with the students directly.
And that's something that's not
captured on the OpenCourseWare
class.
But I would stay with
Jamie and our TA Siri,
for at least two hours
every day after class,
just talking to students.
And you work with them.
And when you and John
came to do the workshop,
you'd just have direct
interaction with the students.
I really think that's where
the most value came from.
I don't know how you
all feel about that.
CHRIS BOEBEL: I thought that
workshop was great, by the way.
I didn't get a chance to
tell you, it was really nice.
JOSHUA GUNN: I mean,
I thought it was just
great to interact
with the students.
I mean I wasn't immediately
sure how engaged they were,
but I had some sense of
it when I would actually
just sort of sit down with
them and they would directly
ask me questions and
there was that sort
of that direct engagement.
And I guess one would
question how this course could
be done electronically, or via
some kind of distance learning,
or that kind of thing.
Because that seemed
invaluable to me.
That kind of personal contact.
ELIZABETH CHOE: If you
are teacher in Missouri,
for instance, how can you teach
this course without a Chris,
without a George,
and without a Josh.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I mean, there
are versions of us in Missouri.
ELIZABETH CHOE: There are.
JOSHUA GUNN: I have an
alter ego in every state.
ELIZABETH CHOE: You
said something nice
about my home state.
It's on camera, too.
But really, again, you can
watch the OpenCourseWare stuff
to get a sense of just, I mean,
they're just fundamental facts,
I guess, that you
should become aware of.
But I gave a midpoint
survey to the students
of what lectures have
you found most helpful,
and they were all
like, all of them.
Like, Chris' was really helpful
because I got his perspective
as a filmmaker, like as
someone who was, and still is,
in the industry.
And then working with Planet
Nutshell, they were like,
oh I had no idea
how to storyboard.
And it was waving more
helpful than just watching
a video of someone do it.
We were actually
interacting with them.
Your hosting workshop, like how
do you give hosting feedback
not in real time, not live.
I don't know.
JOSHUA GUNN: I just remember
sitting down with a couple
students and I think
students were running
their ideas by both of us.
Maybe me individually,
and John, just
giving sort of direct
creative feedback.
Well, I think that
could work, but have you
thought about doing this?
And then that would spur
them to further sort
of creative thinking.
That kind of interaction,
that relationship,
seemed invaluable.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And the
one on one interaction.
I've thought about that too.
I mean maybe the equivalent of
crowd sourcing or something.
But most of the valuable
experiences I had as a student,
and that I think I've had
with students as a teacher,
are really not even in the
classroom, but one on one.
JOSHUA GUNN: Yeah, I mean, most
of the experiences I remember
most powerfully are
being at office hours
and having a teacher asks
me like, so do you really
think you're going to
be an English major?
CHRIS BOEBEL: And particularly
in media or video,
it's like you have this
work, it's a piece of crap,
and someone is going to sit
there and help you turn it
into something else.
And just to learn what
can be done to a script,
to something that's been
shot and not edited the way
it could be.
It's a really
powerful experience.
JOSHUA GUNN: Yeah definitely.
And so I wonder, sorry
to interrupt you, I just
I just wonder if the balance--
I don't have a complete picture
of how the course was balanced,
because I wasn't there
the whole time, but
I wonder if there
could be more opportunity
for that kind of a one on one
interaction.
CHRIS BOEBEL: It's very short.
That's the challenge.
JOSHUA GUNN: Yeah.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah.
CHRIS BOEBEL: It's
such a short class.
JOSHUA GUNN: Like some kind
of critique or workshop
that maybe we all attended
and gave thoughts on?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: And
for the students
who worked with us in production
week, that was a lot of one
on one.
A lot of one on one, or like,
three on one, in that case.
But there again, for
production week it
was like you don't spend two
hours like, here here's why
your hosting was not optimal.
You just tell them what
to do to fix it quickly
so you can get the next shot.
But that still is
valuable because you still
see how a professional does it.
You're there and
you're doing it.
You're not just
sitting there watching.
Without you, the
show doesn't run.
Without the student,
the show doesn't run.
So they have to do it.
ELIZABETH CHOE: A
couple of the students
who did Science Out
Loud, they waited
to write their final blog
reflection until after they
shot.
So they were like, I wanted to
wait to see how different it
would be from the class.
And even in that one
day, I learned so much.
Like, more than I did in
the two weeks of the class.
Just like being in that
production setting.
Sorry go ahead.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: That was it.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Something
I wanted to mention,
again, this kind of
thing isn't scalable.
We can't spend one on one
time with 20 students.
It was manageable
because there were
only seven or eight of them at
any given time, thank goodness.
Initially were like, yeah
we're going to blow it up,
make it like 24 students.
Oh my gosh, no.
It was a struggle to keep
up even though our teaching
team is huge, just because it
is such an intensive process
to work with them one on one.
But what I did want to make use
of their peer-to-peer learning
and support.
And somehow, I
don't know exactly
know how this got
fostered, but we really
had a nice class environment.
The students were very
supportive of each other,
which was really
nice, maybe because it
was such a small class.
But during the second week,
they would go off in groups
to shoot each other, and
they would give advice
to each other.
Which was awesome.
I would overhear are some
really great directorial advice,
but I would also overhear some
advice that would be like, no.
Don't make them have
that intonation.
I wouldn't say
anything because I
think it's important for
their learning experience.
But that's what
I mean by there's
only so much you
can do with people
in the same sort of learning
sphere teaching each other.
JOSHUA GUNN: It's
a very short-- I
mean so much of what
this class is like,
is characterized by the
fact that it's so short.
Because the cohort
thing is so important.
And, I mean, as someone
who, I'll confess,
went to art school.
I know, sorry MIT people.
So I went to NYU, the graduate
film program, the three year
program.
So the first year
of that program,
is kind of like the first couple
of lectures in your class.
It's all class based, you
feel like your head is
exploding with all this stuff.
And you're hanging on your
professor's every word,
and it's like kind
of transformation.
After that, it's kind of
pointless to go to class.
It doesn't really matter
what happens in the class.
It's all about the
cohort, and it's
all about what you
do outside of class,
and the help and support
you give each other as you
make these iterative projects.
So it kind of takes
over and becomes
the thing, the only thing.
The relationship of the
students with each other,
critiquing each
other's work, working
on each others projects.
The rest of it, once
you kind of have
the basics, the basic
conceptual framework--
GEORGE ZAIDAN: It's
like learn by doing.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah, it's all
learn by doing after that.
ELIZABETH CHOE: The problem
is because it's a two
week, or three week, class.
Or even a semester,
or even a year.
At MIT, I mean, these students
are nowhere near experts.
Not saying that we are,
right, there's only so much
that they can be aware
of with each other,
that it was a weird
balance to strike.